there are questions that you can be  asked which you don't know the answer to  you can't answer  theoretically in advance you know what  would you feel if now you know the  answer to that is meaningless the only  answer to the question is the answer you  give when you are actually faced with  the situation and I think many of us  many of us would discover when faced  with extreme situations that we found in  ourselves resilience that we found  resources that we did not suspect on  ourselves of having because the survival  instinct is unbelievably strong you know  the most powerful instinct of human  beings is the instinct to survive and  when the survival instinct is triggered  it only triggered when you're actually  in an extreme situation you can't summon  up the survival instinct but when it's  triggered it's an incredibly powerful  force it takes hold of you and it says  live live live that you do whatever it  takes